see what happened okay
anything yeah you know you're right uh I
try to block it out you know I mean and
then I think that's worse trying to
block you out you know oh yeah it's
definitely worse to hang onto that stuff
and carry with you it's like a [ __ ]
backpack full of books one sec I gotta
do an uber for somebody
oh yeah / - huh I do everything for
everybody
I think deliver food to people I got you
got to an uber for this girl I do Nikki
yeah oh this is her she's in Las Vegas
now she stopped drinking oh that's cool
totally stop hasn't that had to drink
for probably three weeks
oh and she's had a job in Vegas but
she's got a urinary tract infection and
a respiratory infection oh is it Corona
what's it is it Corona no no no she's
already been in the hospital they said
no it's not that
that's good I'd be tested three times
where do you get tested hospital right
there - Christian Center and that test
you really yeah actually basically it's
an easy test it's just a temperature you
know is that all I do yeah that's how
they do if you got no temperature you
ain't got it but they're worried about
me because for one the HIV you know and
then I got asthma and COPD so they're
kind of worried about me you know but I
seem to be doing okay yeah you seem
healthy as can be you look better today
than you ever you ever have yeah I just
woke up not even 30 minutes ago reason
leading out I was at my friend's tent
over there on uh Central and 15th
he got me out the rain yesterday just
let me sleep it off you know in fact I
don't smoke crack no more yo you you
really crack and heroin yeah I don't do
crack no more oh really
yeah I do a little crystal you know if
crystal helped me get off the crap yeah
I forgot a lot yes and it works it works
yeah yeah I know I I you said I used to
shoot it a lot I just thought that
higher but then I was getting paranoid
like to you so you've used heroin do you
use crack and you use crystal meth an
abused PCP abused everything tell me the
differences in these drugs cocaine is a
stimulant is it straight stimulant you
know I just pick you up but it it drops
you real quick you know bruh
speed is it's a stimulant too but it is
you look there for a while you know but
you're not you don't do such drastic
stuff and a lot of people say it helps
your like libido and all oh yes it's not
it's the bombs for sex is good yeah yeah
you have to try it okay we're getting a
viewers now that it's just when I think
about all the chemicals that they use to
cook it up all the chemicals are under
your kitchen seat yeah it's horrible
stuff yeah like what is this stuff
liquid liquid plumr yeah and then heroin
yeah the heroin it relaxes you
we relaxes your whole system it makes
you forget about all that
yeah you're not yeah just like I do the
high it just relaxes me takes me away
yeah so I don't have to feel from all
your pain and memories yeah yeah PCP
sure good [ __ ] totally eat your your
cells in your head
yeah what the people had talked did it
you know there's guys it you know I had
a friend that tried to lift the gas pump
out of the [ __ ] ground he thought he
was a strong well then it dinners spice
which is a which is oh my god I've never
table
I know these that's that's the poor
man's drug but it's it's it's horrible
yeah it's killing people you know what
it is it's that it's pesticide they use
on it splat for no it's horrible stuff
yeah it's almost the most destructive on
all these drugs yeah and that's what
it's becoming more popular yeah it was
very inexpensive so yeah a dollar yeah
dollar for joint right and then what
else would we miss anything else it I'm
sick of all this stuff what about pills
although no I don't do pills yeah so so
I see you all the time you're one of my
old friends from down here yeah I think
I was one of the first ones well when I
came to this studio but I thought this
is my third studio down okay but I think
I even photographed you years before
yeah maybe I think I was down here I've
been down here like 10 years okay on and
off I wasn't here ten years straight but
I was down here and they left I came
back and I left again and now I'm here
the last year I've been here a lot so
you would once told me what happened
with your childhood your dad molested
you at what age seven years old and it
went on for how long years and you told
me outside the your will you talk about
it one last time you didn't really wanna
get into it and I don't blame you and I
didn't push so well but if you if you
want to share that I think it's if
you're into sharing it oh it can be very
therapeutic it's just he he used to tell
me that it was a game that we would play
you know again and I didn't understand
what what he was saying but in actuality
it was a game because he was
he was acting like I was his wife
instead of his wife you know and I was
his daughter so I didn't understand you
know it was easy it was full six you
know at seven years old you know so
that's how I grew up real real fast you
know and I thought it was okay you know
until I found out that it was really he
was abusing me
hey did your mom find out I tried to
tell my mom and she she would watch it
she would watch it
we need watch it watch it you sit down
watch I think that he threatened her if
he didn't watch then he would kill her
Jesus and you grew up where ed Portland
right again well back there there was in
the 70s it was a lot of incest went on
you know within the church you know I
think there's a lot of incest got
everywhere everywhere after doing all
these interviews at these it's like yeah
you know at first it was fondling just
you know touchy you know but then it got
it got more heavy you know and that's
what scared me did you ever confront
your dad about this later like yeah when
I went to prison and I had my son I had
my son two days later my dad was at the
prison he wanted to see me I said okay I
just totally went off on him I said you
see where I've seen do you see where I'm
sitting you know I remember I haven't
had a conversation with my mom and I
said I would never become a drug addict
go to prison or big angry gangbanger
that day I juiced my life you know cuz
now I've done all those things you know
and I just totally I just told my father
that day you know I said I never want to
see you again you know I don't I don't
want you in my life you know if this is
if this is what it's gonna be about
I don't need it you know and I heard him
you know so I really think he died it
was gonna be hard then you could never
get you know he apologized
he made his amends to me did you seem to
be to have remorse for yeah yeah he did
he had tears in his eyes you know um he
was he was dying then you know he died
the day I got out of prison before I got
up but yeah he died and you were in
prison for what Oh parole violation
that's his serious and you had siblings
yeah I have my sister did she she was
abused she was abused too she doesn't
talk about it though I think that's
what's stopping her from you still never
had babies yeah it's me I get you know I
see comments like how can you how will
force these people to talk about these
things but to not talk about them is
worse is much worse well if somebody
really does want to talk about it like
you didn't last time
I don't pressure you into doing it yes
let it go well but for people that are
willing to talk about it I think it's
can benefit them well and other people
that have been through that and maybe
don't they're not talking about it
oh did your watching and so so you're
using drugs a lot less you told me yeah
so that's about a year ago or so that we
did their first interview and one you
were using how many six up to six
balloons load of heroin and what are you
using now sometimes that thing what do
you behead today no nothing and what
will you use today
one well so you've gone from six down to
one what
and you look you look much better yeah
mentally I've gained a little weight you
you seem a little more a little
healthier calmer your skin looks better
I'll save it son um did you do this on
your own or through a program or how do
you do it you do this by yourself what
would you reckon what would you
recommend to somebody trying to get off
a heroin blue meanie you know go to a
meeting you know many people I've talked
to in the in the ten years I've been
doing this that have kicked heroin Oh
honestly if they've told me they've
kicked heroin but the ones that have
actually done it
Oh zero maybe one
you'll be the first one I'm seeing
example I did it on my own I got tired
of living like that
so you weaned yourself slowly yeah and
then with the method are they helped how
are you doing methadone yeah that's
nothing that saves my life it saved my
life you didn't tell me that
method since 2014
I didn't even go get that today because
it's too late
and then what what what's the long-term
plan with methadone is it is it on it
slowly decrease eventually you'll be off
fat yeah yeah if I could get off that
method I would be so happy cuz it [ __ ]
you up it [ __ ] you up it [ __ ] your
bones up it sensing your your bones I'm
sure that's it is really bad you know
who started that right Hitler really for
his people his army giving them
methadone
yeah they helped him with the paint yeah
yeah but now the federal government
gives it to us and you have kids right
yeah my dad is a brain surgeon
really yeah we're at USC awesome yeah
and she knows you're down here yeah
she's waiting for me to tell her to come
and pick me up mom you're almost there
yeah mom was there that's great he's he
calls me she's uh I got her on speed
speed I'll see you torture your daughter
yeah every day every day every day
that's great even if my mom [ __ ] up
I'll be like you don't want to talk to
me right now and she's like I don't care
I don't care she doesn't care yeah
that's great yeah it's beautiful
she's help me help me no I think that
acceptance and non-judgmental
interaction whoa careful a best friend
that I never had she says like but mom
there's rats down here
really yeah she just she just turned 32
she's a brain surgeon yeah
she'll never be without a job she got
top honors she got she was bad about
dick Torian of her class she was like
number two in the class and she was
raised by it
I knew you raised her yeah so you've
been even letting on the streets this
way yeah since 1985 yeah I thought hi 85
she was how old she was
I had heard 88 so hold on you were
homeless when you had your daughter yeah
and you raised her where well you know
through to family you know to my aunts
and stuff she woke up of me for a little
while but she wasn't staying on Skid Row
no she was staying with family Wow and
then you would come in come and go yeah
all right so yeah so you had some help
yeah that's great yeah but you certainly
is doing something my kids were never
into foster homes are nothing like that
you know they don't know nothing about
that that they they don't they don't
they don't judge me from she says mom
everybody has their skeletons isn't it
don't you as an addict feel like that's
almost the most important element in
recovery yeah that's good good night
tonight where you come from - I'm sorry
we don't forget where you come from
yeah you can always get back every time
you fall it's that much worse I've made
25 step I'll take a hundred steps and
they come back 50 yes well Jennifer it's
so great to see you thank you I see all
the time thank you for this needs to be
you're amazing
I'm so proud of you Thanks and I'm proud
of your daughter - thank you I'm gonna
bring her down here I'm gonna bring out
okay well maybe go have lunch or
something
you